I'm Dave and welcome to your part 1 of 5
episodic news updates yoshinoya class a
director and producer of various Final
Fantasy titles throughout the series
history has further explained Square
Enix's decision to deliver final fantasy
7 as an episodic multi-part series
catarse who direct original 1999
PlayStation release said the development
team had the opportunity to go beyond
the story world and experience of final
fantasy 7 in ways we've always dream of
and he took this opportunity from the
depths of Midgar through the skies above
the planet the multi-platform at enables
us to expand the story and turn it into
an epic experience for fans and new
gamers alike quitarse went on to restate
that attempting to fit everything from
the original into one installment as
opposed to releasing episodically would
have resulted in compromises we would
have to cut various parts and create a
new condensed version of Final Fantasy 7
he explained we knew none of you would
have wanted that I hope that by
explaining a little more about our
design decisions that you can appreciate
the size of this project and what we
have planned for this remake going
beyond the scale and depth the world
narrative and gameplays original to
deliver something that feels familiar
yet new as I said before we like
delivering surprises this is the second
time the Contessa's defended the
decision on December 7th he said a
proper HD remake of Final Fantasy 7 that
maintains the same feeling of density of
the original results in a volume of
content that couldn't possibly fit into
one installment on a 76 square enix
announced Final Fantasy 7 remake will
play across a multi-part series with
each entry providing its own unique
experience so what do you think of the
choice to go episodic are you excited
what does the change confuse and terrify
you let us know in the comments below or
you can find me on Twitter at a regular
Dave and for more news on Final Fantasy
7 stay tuned to gamespot com
you